over centuries the art and public
Galleries and history books has been
curated to celebrate and teach us about
revered artists throughout human history
but as Holly Williams reports now from
London there's something pretty
significant they've all been leaving out
from Da Vinci and Botticelli to Picasso
and Warhol name a famous artist off the
top of your head and the chances are
it'll be a man
the male gaze dominates the walls of
Galleries and museums
here in London the national galleries
collection just one percent of it is
made up of art by women Katie Hessel
wants to change that an art historian
who set out to revolutionize her field
her new book provocatively titled the
story of art without men is a history of
art made exclusively by women when you
were studying at University and you were
hearing mainly male names did that
strike you at the time you know what
terribly it didn't I didn't even
consider it it was actually after
University when I was 21 I had this
almost Epiphany I walked into an art
fair and I realized out of the thousands
of Works in front of me not a single one
was by a woman we met Hessel at a new
exhibition of work by the American
Artist Alice Neal she's only really had
one Museum show before and she's a huge
figure she lived in New York City from
the 1930s the 1980s and she painted
people of all walks of life women have
been making art since its very
Beginnings often acclaimed in their own
time but somehow Hessel says they've
been written out of their rightful place
in history a case in point is Artemisia
gentileschi whose work was prized by the
nobility in 17th century Italy in the
opening page of my book I start with a
quote by her from 1649 she says I'll
show you what a woman can do
100 years ago Angelica Kaufman was the
go-to Portrait Painter for the British
aristocracy in the 18th century and a
founding member of the Royal Academy she
was extraordinary she would demand the
same prices as her male counterparts yet
how many people have heard of her and
edmonia Lewis was an African-American
sculptor so popular in the 19th century
that her studio in Rome became a tourist
destination why had I not heard of her
until I read your book because so much
of art history leaves these incredible
women out I think it's about who has
told that story who has chosen what
sculptures what paintings to put on our
Gallery walls Claudette Johnson is a
British Artist who's just had her first
solo show in New York she told us even
today if you want to be a successful
artist it helps to be male do you feel
that you've been denied attention or
denied success that male artists have
been given at this moment in time no I
don't
but um if you left me that 20 years ago
then yes I I would I felt that as a
woman of color she told us it's been
especially hard and part of the problem
is who decides which art is valuable
owning works of art
still seems to be mainly
accessible only to the most wealthy in
society
um
and which is mainly rich white people
which is made me rich white people
[Music]
changing Johnson told us an anonymous
group of masked protesters called the
Guerrilla girls has been fighting back
against sexism and racism in art since
the 1980s with eye-catching posters on
the streets of Manhattan this online
campaign featuring Barbie dolls is
drawing attention to the lack of women
artists in major Galleries and now for
the first time ever women are in charge
of the Louvre in Paris the National
Gallery of Art in Washington DC and the
Tate galleries in Britain do you feel
excited or do you feel like
why is this taking so long why have we
had to work so hard for this yes it is
worth waiting but it's taken so long to
get even here
and providing to know that there's
further to go but on the other hand I'm
really happy that we are on that Journey
Katie Hessel wants the Forgotten great
female artist of History to finally be
given their due we can count how many
women artists are on the walls of our
museums we can talk to our friends and
say actually can you even name three or
five or ten women artists there is so
much learning that we can do in order
for equality to happen in the future
for CBS Saturday morning Holly Williams
London
it's really true I mean think about when
she just said that name can you name
five female artists just right off the
top of your head it's it's a lot harder
than just name five male artists think
of the name itself history she said art
history his story yeah
says a lot